[Music]
foreign
Titans from the previous Godzilla and
Kong movies of the monster verse will
they appear in gxk the new Empire and
gxk the hunted this is a question that
is now currently swimming in the minds
of most of us and Kaiju fans as a whole
so here in this video we will showcase
what we do know about them and whether
or not the fan favorites will make a
comeback in the upcoming movie and
Comics so let's get to it let's start
with Rodan in Godzilla King of the
Masters Rodan survived the Boston battle
and show respected Godzilla positioning
himself as a potential ally in the
future being used in future most of us
installments maybe while he didn't
really appear in Godzilla vs skong a
prequel graphic novel revealed that he
and other Titans were in hibernation
called back by godzillicus he was tired
of the talents roaming around the
upcoming sequel hints at an Undiscovered
threat that could challenge Godzilla and
God's existence potentially leading to a
powerful set of villains requiring
further assistance than just attacked
him with Kong this could very well set
the stage for a Godzilla Rodan team up
again aligning with dead Toho film
history where they have teamed up before
so this will be one to watch for
now coming to Mothra the queen of the
monsters died in kotm but it was
revealed that she laid an egg before the
faithful battle therefore preserving her
immortality but since it took her quite
a very long time to hatch from the
previous egg therefore she might not be
seen again for a very long time in the
future the chances of Mothra appearing
again in the most of us movies or shows
is highly unlikely a near zero percent
probability although we do want her
badly
okay now the Titans the Behemoth silver
Tiamat and Hulu nakika Etc
these fan favorites were seen in king of
the monsters and then again in other
Comics like Godzilla Dominion Behemoth
as of now is recovering from the battle
with amhulu which he almost lost if not
for the intervention of Godzilla we
might not be seeing him in action again
as he has already been used twice and
furthermore he will appear again in
Monarch Declassified Comics stressing
the stories of not just him but the
other Titans as well the same goes to
Silla who was also seen last in Godzilla
Dominion actually fighting the G-Man and
taking a huge loss guessing that their
battle against shimu and Scar would
mostly focus on the hollow Earth and
also terrestrial environments we might
not be seeing aquatic titles like Tiamat
or nakika in the upcoming GSK movies
although we might see them in the
Monarch Declassified content work and
the gxk the hunted comics we are
definitely going to get um along with
Behemoth in the same work again this
time from the perspectives of these two
Titans and what were the real reason for
the fight in the Amazon that Godzilla
had to break up they still have a chance
at screen time in the series though
okay yeah we forgot Methuselah this
gigantic quadrupedal Titan that is gray
having a large Jagged Mountain on his
back which was a result of the
millennial long hibernation this guy
sleeps a lot and is currently in
hibernation Methuselah was created to
show that Titans can be a part of the
natural world and so in the upcoming gxk
flick he might be seen fighting a losing
battle against the villains that
threatened the natural order of things
so look at this from this perspective he
is an example of the natural world
coexisting and all that and the villains
are a threat to the Natural author of
things he would make for a great
sacrificial lamb in order to unite other
Titans against shimu and Scar King but
that's just my opinion
next the mutos and skull crawlers these
are the ones that are highly unlikely to
be seen again not for their divergent
storylines or designs or all that but
because they have been used Too Much see
the mirrors was seen in the first
Godzilla film then again in king of the
monsters they were also featured well as
Mutual Prime in Godzilla Aftershock and
then they will be a big part in either
monarchy classified all its Series in
the legacy of titans the same goes for
the skull crawlers they were seen first
in Kong Skull Island of 2017 then again
in Godzilla vs is gone and mentioned
briefly in the novelizations of kotm and
will see it again in brief in the
animated Skull Island Series so putting
these two monsters again in gxk will be
more like milking a dead cow
now what about Doug so in the 2021 movie
Godzilla vs Kong there was a brief
appearance of what would become a fan
favorite Dirk titanus Doug a massive
predatory reptile belonging to an
unidentified species native to the
hollow Earth the director Adam Wingard
aimed for duck species to share some
resemblance with Godzilla although the
movie does not really explicitly
establish an evolutionary connection
between these two species his name was
actually given by fans and then adopted
by the director himself which tells us
how beloved this brief character was so
I am pretty sure we will see Doug again
or his species in both jsk the hunted as
well as in gxk the new Empire as to
their role in the movie or the comics
I'm guessing that it won't be much more
than being background fauna to the
desolate Hollow Earth them along with
the war bats Maybe
okay so the feline Titan so yeah there
will be new creatures and titles that
will be showcased in the hollow Earth
because it seemed like a Barren
Wasteland in GVK and GSK should remedy
it anyway in a leaked image of jsk the
hunted we actually saw a new creature
although a smaller one fighting against
Kong ambushing The Big Ape from behind a
waterfall I would guess this would not
end well for the meow it looks to be
around 50 to 60 feet tall on all fours
compared to Kong who is over 300 feet in
height around the size of a skull devil
which would not be much of a challenge
to the killer of Mechagodzilla
and lastly wolf Titans so from leaked
information that we have heard which was
generated from the two or three
screenings for the movie it seems that
Kong will in the beginning of the story
fight off against a couple of large
wolf-like Titans maybe just canine
tyrants that are endemic to the hollow
Earth this will be somewhat like Ralph
and George from Rampage but in more
Titanic proportions I must say that this
isn't confirmed but if it is it would be
great as com would have to fight his way
to the top of the food chain and to be
the king of that place the Apex position
would not be handed over in a silver
platter
so that's all I have to say about the
Titans appearing in gxk the new Empire
and The Hunted so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos here on
this channel till the next one take care
fam